[Musique]
vous ne les connaissez pas encore mais
vous feriez peut-être bien de retenir
leur
nom ceux qui battent le pavé parisien
cette semaine sont les jeunes champions
réunionnés du Seddas le centre
départemental artistique pour
l'animation et la culture des enfants
ils sont les champions ils ont réussi au
championnat régional d'authographe et de
calcul et la récompense c'est un séjour
culturel àar et on le fait depuis 40 ans
parce qu'on existe depuis 40 ans le sdas
est né de l'initiative d'un groupe
d'enseignants réunionnés dont fait
partie Séline avec un objectif principal
mettre fin à l'ilétrisme à la Réunion
pour les 14 écoliers arrivés cette
semaine c'est un Paris gagné au
programme plusieurs visites des lieux
incontournables de la capitale c'est
incroyable parce que j'ai jamais vu de
ça c'est la première fois il y a pas
tout le monde qui peut faire ça c'est
unique et je me rends compte qu'on peut
pas faire ça tout le temps donc il faut
en profiter j'ai pas visité très souvent
la capitale de
France je suis en train de voir des
monuments emblématique qui représente la
France ils ont ils ont ils ont ils ont
traversé le temps pour pour que je les
voir
et je remercie beaucoup le sedas d'avoir
de m'avoir offert ce magnifique séjour
culturel à Paris et un tel séjour se
mérite avec de nombreuses dans les mé et
bus parisiens et des visites qui
donneront à nos champions beaucoup
d'inspiration parmi ell celle du Palais
du Luxembourg siège le Sénat palais
royal pour quelle raison par que de qui
construire ce palais une écoute
studieuse pour ceux qui étaient encore
il y a quelques heures à plus de 10000
km de là de quoi épat également le guide
de la
matinée c'est un public qui est très
facile à captiver qui est plus facile
également c'est d'avoir des des enfants
qui sont qui ont le souci de connaître
ces institutions parlementaires qu' y
arrivent plein de plein de questions
plein de bonne humeur et voilà qui sont
toujours en demande pour moi ça permet
de concrétiser les choses leur faire
voir comment on travaille dans une
institution parlementaire et puis comme
ils viennent de la réunion de
concrétiser
aussi tout ce qui se passe à Paris
et voilà tout ce qui peut ça peut leur
servir pour la suite je pense un accès
rare au bijoux de la République
rendu possible grâce à l'invitation de
la sénatrice réunionnaise Viviane
my c'est bien oui é une belle visite ça
s bien passé beaucoup de questions
beaucoup plein les yeux de la beauté du
Sénat c'est tous les ans des des groupes
que je reçois
volontiers c'est vrai que cela
suscite des questions cela suscite des
vocations c'est magnifique à voir et
c'est vrai que ça suscite beaucoup de
sourire et de lumière dans les
yeux la vocation y
est c'est quandme la place de Victor
Hugo c'est impressionnant de se dire
qu'il a été là il y a plus d'une plus
d'une centaine d'Ann et même si on se
sent parfois tout petit face à la
renommée des
lieux certains déjà mordus de politique
se laisse aller à des rêves de
grandeur je remercie vraiment encore le
département pour ce c'est vrai que c'est
vraiment inspirant parce que en tant que
président du conseil départemental j'ai
toujours voulu m'investir dans la vie
politique donc française et c'est vrai
que en voyant ce ce lieu aujourd'hui ça
a vraiment j'ai vraiment eu une vocation
je me suis dit que peut-être un jour je
serai présidente du Sénat pourquoi pas
je me suis dit vraiment que c'était fait
pour moi et que je visais je visais
vraiment ha leur permettre de viser haut
c'est l'objectif du département comme
nous le rappelle Sabrina tow élu
départemental jeunes qu'on qu'on a
aujourd'hui et bien il faut qu'on leur
donne les moyens et le Conseil
départemental est là pour les aider là
aujourd'hui on a des enfants qui n'ont
jamais quitté l'île et qui pour une fois
bon écoutez euh ils ont pris l'avion
pour la première fois il faut absolument
partir il faut qu'on qu'on voit ailleur
comment ça se passe prendre tout ce que
le monde peut leur offrir pour pouvoir
euh se donner les moyens de réussir dans
leur propre île peut-être pour mieux
revenir et ou pas mais au moins avoir
cette cette ambition d'y aller parce que
c'est c'est avec ça qu'on s'enrichit il
ne nous reste plus qu'à patienter
quelques années pour assister à la suite
de leur chemin bien entamé vers la
réussite nos champions rentreront à la
réunion avec la tête dans les étoiles
j'espère que d'autres rayonnais qui vont
gagner pour participer parce que c'est
très très cool on s'est amusé on a on
est parti au Champs-Élysée on a vu la
tourf on fait plein de belles rencontres
que ce soit au niveau des
accompagnateurs ou ou des qui sont ici
aussi on a découvert de nouvelles choses
on est parti à l' lcé j'ai vraiment
adoré cette semaine le mot je choisira
pour cette semaine ce serait le mot
exceptionnel c'était cool c'était
impressionnant cool
bien je dirais fascinante du coup je
m'intéresse beaucoup plus à la politique
et j'ai envie d'être présidente pour une
fois qu'il a une
femme